il y a fort longtemps salut j'ai eu
droit à un énorme mariage à la grecque
désormais ma fille est grande j'espère
que tu as fait des demandes au fac du
coin pourquoi les parents disent qu'on
doit avoir des rêves mais surtout pas
trop grand avec yann on essaie de se
garder un peu de temps pour nous
qu'est ce que vous faites pharma famille
est toujours aussi présente les parents
aussi au droit à une vie sexuelle
ils me suivent partout j'ai besoin d'air
ta mère disait la même chose sur les
grecs la floride au texas new york ce
sont les fagots j'ai fait des demandes
d'inscription pourquoi tu veux quitter
camair ça fait mal mais il y a toujours
quelques surprises
le prêtre n'a jamais signé le certificat
de mariage
on n'est pas marié je suis une vie pire
ma famille s'est à nouveau réuni qui a
dit qu'une femme devait être marié toit
depuis toujours le mariage comment pour
organiser magnifique
un autre grand mariage à la grecque
même si je décide de prendre un peu mes
distances je serai toujours là
nous venons d'une longue lignée de
femmes de tête n'oublie pas les yeux
ouverts les cuisses fermes mais si tu
écartes les cuisses ma chérie alors
ferme les yeux